it's a clearance sale on Clarence Thomas
according to a bombshell report from
propublica Supreme Court Justice
Clarence Thomas has been secretly
accepting gifts in the form of luxury
vacation from billionaire Republican
donor Harlan Crowe and failed to
disclose them for over 20 years and a
second propublica report revealed that
one of Crowe's companies purchased two
vacant Lots in a house from Thomas and
His relatives in 2014 which Thomas also
failed to disclose also the home just
happens to house one Leona Williams
Clarence Thomas's mom who the
billionaire donor has allowed to live
there rent free and now a Washington
Post investigation discovered that
Thomas has for decades claimed income
from a real estate company that no
longer exists the Optics alone here are
terrible these luxury trips and real
estate sales are potentially worth
millions of dollars in benefits flowing
from a conservative billionaire Mega
donor toward one of the nine votes that
have basically unchecked power over the
whole U.S legal system and Justice
Thomas determined that he had no
obligation to disclose any of this until
he was caught and frankly upon examining
the toothless ethics laws in place for
our nation's top court and the apparent
lack of political will to enforce the
laws that we actually do have Justice
Thomas may be right now before diving
into the Clarence Thomas Saga let's talk
about the key players here first we have
the inheritor of a Dallas real estate
Fortune Harlan Crow who is a long time
Mega donor to Republican candidates
causes and organizations now a few years
after Justice Thomas joined the Supreme
Court in 1991 Crow met Clarence Thomas
and his wife Ginny and in the years that
followed they claimed to have become
close friends though importantly in the
years after he became a Supreme Court
Justice now Crow is also a major donor
to the Federalist Society a conservative
legal organization Crow has publicly
given more than 10 million dollars in
political contributions and probably
more via undisclosed dark money
donations but when asked about his
contributions Crow once told the New
York Times and he quote does not
disclose what I'm not required to
disclose now on April 6 2023 Pro publica
revealed that Clarence Thomas has
accepted luxury trips nearly every year
from Crow without listing them on his
Federal disclosure forms in June of 2019
Justice Thomas and his wife Jenny flew
on Crow's bomb your Global 5000 jet to
Indonesia then boarded Crow's 162-foot
super yacht for nine days of island
hopping the total cost of the trip would
have exceeded 500 000 had the Thomas's
chartered the plane and the fully
staffed yacht themselves according to
the report Thomas went on at least six
trips on Crow's private jet including to
Indonesia Upstate New York and New Haven
Connecticut Thomas also traveled with
Crow to the Bohemian Grove and exclusive
California all-male retreat and visited
crows Ranch in East Texas and one week
per year Thomas would vacation at Crow's
private Resort in the Adirondacks and
this is certainly much different from
the more humble and down-to-earth image
that Justice Thomas has attempted to
cultivate over the years you know I
don't have any problem with going to
Europe but I prefer the United States
and I prefer seeing the regular parts of
the United States I prefer going across
the rural areas I prefer the RV parks I
prefer the Walmart parking lots to the
beaches and things like that uh yeah
sure I'm I'm sure that's the case and
just a week after the initial report on
April 13th propublica published details
of an October 2014 real estate
transaction between Crow and the Thomas
family according to public documents one
of Crow's companies paid just over 133
thousand dollars for two vacant lots and
a single-family home that were co-owned
by Thomas his mother and the family of
Thomas's late brother the transaction
which had not previously been disclosed
was the first known instance of money
flowing directly from the Republican
Mega donor to a Supreme Court Justice
now under the terms of the sale Crow
allowed Justice Thomas's then 85 year
old mother Leola Williams to live in her
home for the rest of her life she lives
there currently rent free but is
responsible for property taxes and
insurance and after the sale was
completed contractors then undertook
extensive Renovations of the house then
on top of those transactions according
to an April 16th article by The
Washington Post Thomas has reported
hundreds of thousands of dollars of
income from a firm called ginger limited
partnership for two decades the problem
here is that the real estate firm found
by his wife and relatives has not
existed since 2006. the company's assets
were taken over by a similarly named
Ginger Holdings LLC but Thomas's
disclosure forms make no mention of a
newer firm now given the similarity of
names it's possible that the company was
just listed in error but it merits
mentioned given Thomas's decades-long
history of non-disclosure in a statement
provided to propublica Crow describes
the Thomas's as quote very dear friends
and defended the trips as the kind of
hospitality he extends to all their
close friends quote we have been most
fortunate to have a great life of many
friends and financial success and we've
always placed a priority on spending
time with our family and friends with
respect to the property purchase Crow
City purchased the home with a plan to
turn it into a public museum honoring
Clarence Thomas while he claimed the
transaction was at market rate Crow
purchased a vacant lot in a house on the
same block for forty thousand dollars
the prior year Crow did not explain why
he bought the two vacant Lots but
indicated that they had been sold Crow
also asserted that he has never
attempted to influence Justice Thomas on
any legal or political issue and claims
he is unaware of any friends that
attempting to influence Thomas on the
same but at the same time Crow serves on
the board of multiple groups that have
advocated at the Supreme Court through
the filing of amicus briefs and in 2005
a company called Trammel Crow
residential that was formed by Harlan
Crowe's father and partly owned by
Harlan Crowe was defendant in a case
before The Supreme Court Clarence Thomas
did not recuse himself from that case in
response to propublica's reporting
Clarence Thomas defended the trips and
pleaded ignorance that it was wrong and
in a rare statement stated quote
Heartland and Kathy Crowe are among our
dearest friends and we have been friends
for over 25 years as friends do we've
joined them on a number of family trips
during the more than quarter Century we
have known them early in my tenure at
the court I saw guidance from my
colleagues and others in the Judiciary
and was advised that this sort of
personal Hospitality from close personal
friends who did not have business before
the court was not reportable I've
endeavored to follow that Council
throughout my tenure and have always
sought to comply with the disclosure
guidelines these guidelines are now
being changed as the committee of the
judicial conference responsible for
financial disclosures for the entire
Federal Judiciary just this past last
month announced new guidance and it is
of course my intent to follow this
guidance in the future now this
statement raises far more questions than
it answers for example while Thomas
acknowledges being gifted family trips
from Crow and perhaps others he does not
address the use of Crow's plane for
other reasons and as we'll talk about
later travel and the actual vacation
itself are treated differently for
example in 2016 Thomas used Crow's plane
for a direct three-hour trip to and from
New Haven Connecticut which would have
cost about seventy thousand dollars and
it appears that Thomas might have been
the only one on that plane and obviously
no one would ever vacation in New Haven
Connecticut so the trip must have been
for some other reason additionally
Thomas asserts that he sought guidance
within the Judiciary and was advised
that his Hospitality from close personal
friends was not reportable but Thomas
doesn't specify who advised him whether
they had any expertise whatsoever
whether they were self-interested in
that advice whether this occurred before
or after befriending Crow or whether he
followed up after this initial advice
within the 30 years that this has been
going on and while Thomas claimed that
he has always sought to comply with
disclosure guidelines the justice has a
documented history of forgetting to
disclose certain things in 2011 Thomas
amended prior forums to reflect income
his wife earned between 1998 and 2003
from the Heritage Foundation which is a
conservative think tank which Thomas
claimed was inadvertently omitted a 2004
LA Times report revealed that Thomas had
accepted private plane trips and
expensive gifts including a Bible that
was previously owned by Frederick
Douglass valued at nineteen thousand
dollars and an a bust of Abraham Lincoln
valued at fifteen thousand dollars the
article also noted the crow had donated
175 thousand dollars for a new Clarence
Thomas Wing at the Justice's childhood
library in Georgia and after the Times
report Thomas continued to take plane
trips from Crow he just stopped
disclosing them and propublica is not
the first publication to raise questions
about the relationship between Crow and
the Thomas family in 2011 the New York
Times detailed numerous favors of the
Texas billionaire had done for the
Thomases including helping to finance a
library dedicated to the Justice in
Savannah Georgia and providing five
hundred thousand dollars for Ginny
Thomas to start a tea party conservative
activism Group which came with a 120 000
a year salary for Jenny Thomas and in a
move that stirred controversy at the
time Crow financed a multi-million
dollar restoration of a cannery that
included a museum about the culture and
history of pinpoint Georgia a pet
project of the associate Justice now
Crow says he hasn't tried to influence
Thomas on any issue and it's true the
people who are ideologically aligned are
probably more likely to become friends
but if a billionaire gave my partner 500
000 to start a political organization
flew us around the world on a private
jet bought property for me that would
both house my mother for the rest of her
life and promise to have that house
turned into a museum honoring me well
you might question the independence of
this channel
Harlan call me now Thomas's former law
clerk James ho who currently sits on the
fifth Circuit Court of Appeals defended
his former boss by suggesting that the
hypocritical double standards were at
play saying that quote there's a big
difference between actual corruption and
the appearance of corruption but even if
there isn't any quid pro quo between
Crow and Thomas the entire Crux of
judicial ethics is based on avoiding any
appearance of impropriety but under 28
U.S code section 455 any federal judge
including these Supreme Court Justices
are supposed to recuse themselves from
any proceeding quote in which his or her
impartiality might reasonably be
questioned unfortunately there are
neither official rules nor a legal
mechanism to force the justices to
recuse themselves and chief justice
Roberts has long resisted calls to
impose a code of ethics on the Supreme
Court and not surprisingly there is a
wide-ranging debate on this topic
multiple legal experts told propublica
that these Dawn disclosures were not
just unethical but may have broken the
law specifically the ethics and
Government Act of 1978 and in a bit of
cheekiness from Congress the
Congressional research service put out a
helpful explainer of this law following
quote a recent article detailing
undisclosed trips by an associate
Justice whoever that could be of course
as you may know finding a great lawyer
can be hard that is until now my firm
the eagle team is now accepting new
clients if you've been injured in a car
accident medical malpractice or just
about anything or you just need a lawyer
we can help represent you or find you
the right attorney because you don't
need a legal team you need the eagle
team just check out the link in the
description now back to Clarence
Thomas's Shenanigans now the ethics and
government actor IGA was passed in the
aftermath of Watergate in part to quote
preserve and promote the Integrity of
public officials and institutions to
achieve this goal I get established
financial reporting requirements for
many high-level government officials and
employees including Supreme Court
Justices the judicial Conference of the
United States the principal policy
making body for the federal courts has
Authority Under the IGA to administer
the financial disclosure requirements
for judicial officers and employees and
under IGA the Attorney General is
authorized to bring enforcement actions
against any individuals who violate the
Law's disclosure requirements those who
knowingly and willfully fail to file or
report any required information face
fines of up to seventy one thousand
dollars per emission adjusted for
inflation and in addition those who
knowingly and willfully falsify
information can face fines and up to a
year in prison now some have argued that
Thomas did knowingly and willfully
violate these statutes under the
pertinent rules disclosures must include
the quote identity of the source and a
brief description and the value of all
gifts well the judicial conference
filing instructions say that all gifts
over 415 dollars must be disclosed in
addition the failure to disclose the 133
000 sale of property from the Thomas
family to Crow could also be a violation
justices are required to report a brief
description the date and category of
value of any purchase sale or exchange
which exceeds one thousand dollars in
real property now there is a personal
Hospitality exemption to disclosure
which provides that any food lodging or
entertainment received as personal
Hospitality of an individual need not be
reported but it's likely that parts of
these trips might not fall under that
exception the ACT defines personal
Hospitality as Hospitality extended for
a non-business purpose by an individual
not a corporation or organization at the
personal residence of that individual or
the individual's family or on property
or facilities owned by that individual
or the individual's family a yacht and
air travel are not food lodging or
entertainment and it seems that
disclosure should have been required
under the relevant acts though in March
of 2023 the judicial conference
clarified the Contours of this exception
which the authors argue reinforced this
reading quote the personal Hospitality
gift reporting exemption applies only to
food lodging or entertainment and the
reporting exemption does not include
gifts other than food lodging or
entertainment such as transportation
that substitutes for commercial
transportation though a good lawyer
would argue that if you have to clarify
it that's not the interpretation that
existed before the clarification and as
luck would have it we do have a fairly
recent prosecution for failure to
disclose under IGA in March of 2022 a
federal judge ordered ex-apprentice star
turned Trump Aid Omarosa Manigold Newman
to pay 61 585 in civil penalties for
knowingly and willfully violating IGA
for her acrimonious firing in 2017. in
his 15-page opinion judge Richard Leon
of the DC District Court found that
Omarosa had received countless reminders
from Administration attorneys of her
legal obligation to file a termination
report Financial disclosure Within 30
days of being fired and those arguing
that Thomas knowingly and willfully
failed to disclose past gifts point to
the fact that in 1997 Thomas disclosed
that Crow flew him to the Bohemian Grove
on a private plane that travel along
with Crow's history of lavishing Thomas
with gifts was reported by the L.A times
in 2004 which Drew lots of criticism but
for the next 20 years Thomas apparently
decided to keep accepting flights from
Crow but just didn't report it anymore
so Thomas's statement that he received
advice telling him that he didn't have
to report plane and Yacht trips doesn't
really comport with the fact that he
used to disclose this information but
then chose not to now many observers
have unfavorably compared Thomas's
example to that of Justice Abe Fortis
who ended up resigning from the Supreme
Court in 1969 after his own payment
scandal in 1968 LBJ nominated Justice
Fortis to succeed Earl Warren as the
chief justice but an investigation
revealed that Fortis had been paid
fifteen thousand dollars to be an
Adjunct professor at American University
but funding came from some of fortis's
old firm and clients some of which came
before the court Fortis would later
request to withdraw his nomination but
opted to stay on the court but in 1969
it was revealed that Fortis took a
twenty thousand dollar retainer from the
Family Foundation of an indicted
security swindler Louis Wolfson
President Nixon hoping to fill a liberal
Supreme Court seat with a conservative
began leaking information to the press
to pressure Fortis to resign now
fortis's conduct was not technically
illegal at the time but Chief Justice in
fortis's friend Justice Hugo Black urged
Fortis to resign to protect the
Integrity of the Court reluctantly
Fortis resigned and Republican Nixon got
his wish but don't expect Clarence
Thomas to resign anytime soon but the
question remains who can launch an
investigation into the Supreme Court
well by law the doj May initiate an
investigation on its own or the request
of the judicial conference Democratic
senator Sheldon Whitehouse of Rhode
Island and representative Hank Johnson
of Georgia have sent a letter requesting
the judicial conference investigate
writing quote there is at least
reasonable cause to believe that Justice
Thomas intentionally disregarded the
disclosure requirement by not reporting
the 2014 property sales to Crow but
there's not a lot of examples of the
judicial conference making such
referrals nor the doj prosecuting them
in 2014 the digital conference referred
judge Boyce Martin a Carter appointee to
the sixth circuit to the doj's public
Integrity unit to investigate
allegations of improper travel
reimbursements but the department
decided not to pursue charges after
Judge Martin who had retired in 2013
voluntarily repaid the 138 thousand
dollars he had received as travel
reimbursements during the contested
four-year period even though he said
only a fraction had been challenged okay
it's Devin from the future and there's
been a lot of new developments so much
so that I'd move things around in my set
so it looks slightly different now now
Clarence Thomas has not denied any of
the facts in the propublica article and
Thomas's Defenders assert that the whole
story is nothing more than a smear
campaign by bitter Democrats though
should be noted that some of Thomas's
public defenders have also accepted
money in fancy trips from Harlan Crowe
for example over the National Review
lawyer Mark pauletta wrote a story with
the following headline Justice Thomas
acted properly and was not required to
disclose his trips
seems totally legit though I should warn
you that the article includes a
world-class disclaimer full disclosure I
worked on Justice Thomas's confirmation
as a lawyer in the White House in 1991.
I have co-edited a book on him titled
created equal Clarence Thomas in his own
words and remain close friends with him
I have also represented Jenny Thomas in
the January 6 committee inquiry now a
disclaimer to the disclaimer this
doesn't even tell the full story of his
relationship with Thomas and Crow
pauletta worked on the confirmations of
Justice's Thomas Gorsuch and Kavanaugh
and oh yeah he was also a guest with
Harlan Crowe on the very same trips as
Thomas himself here he is with Justice
Thomas at camp topridge in the painting
commemorating one of those vacations
truly a masterful painting that really
captures the essence of the photograph
which was also taken of the exact same
spot and it also captures the delicate
light reflecting off of Harlan Crow's
calves but paletta's argument is that
Thomas wasn't required to disclose the
vacations because the personal
Hospitality requirement is brand new and
in an equally baffling follow-up piece
pellet addresses the sale of the house
that Thomas's mother lived in the Crux
of the argument is this quote in the
Years preceding this transaction Justice
Thomas and his wife put significant sums
of money into making improvements to his
mother's house given these costs their
one-third share of its sale price
amounted to a capital loss on a property
because of that Justice Thomas did not
believe that the sale of his mother's
home was a reportable transaction this
is without exaggeration insane the
relevant statute as you've seen requires
disclosure of quote any sale which
exceeds one thousand dollars in Real
Property other than the property used
solely as a personal residence of the
reporting individual or the individual
spouse it makes no distinction between
whether the sale was for a profit or
loss it kind of makes you question
Thomas's ability to understand you know
the law meanwhile Justice John Roberts
turned down a request to testify in
front of the senate about the unreported
gifts travel and real estate
transactions instead he sent a letter
stating that the justices are all
ethical all nine justices signed a
document attached to the letter entitled
statement of Ethics principles and
practices Robert suggested that there
was a separation of powers issue with
asking the Chief Justice to appear
before the Senate he points out that
only two justices and three presidents
have ever done so though it does make
one wonder what kind of checks and
balances there are if the Supreme Court
can't be forced to testify in the face
of potentially huge corruption and as
the Chief Justice acknowledges a
testimony of justices and presidents is
rare but not unheard of the two justices
who testified to Congress in the past
were questioned about administrative
matters so the Chief Justice implies
that it's fine to go to the Senate to
talk about minor issues but it's somehow
Beyond The Pale for the chief judge to
address serious ethical issues now
obviously the justices fear additional
embarrassing disclosures for example
nine days after his confirmation Justice
Neil Gorsuch sold a property that had
languished on the market for two years
he disclosed the sale but left the buyer
section blank the buyer turned out to be
the leader of a law firm with surprise
many cases in front of the Supreme Court
now these accusations have come out
against Clarence Thomas but they'd be
astounding if any justice had committed
them and of course these are only the
facts that we know about for all we know
Justice Sotomayor might be being flown
around the world by Bill Gates and Kagan
is getting hundreds of thousands of
dollars of vacations from Larry Ellison
and all of that would be super bad but
the lack of Ethics or enforcement is a
real problem with no easy solution there
are real separation of powers issues and
the Supreme Court
interprets the law and also Congress is
pretty much deadlocked on everything so
it's not likely that any of this is
likely to change anytime soon and
pauletta stepped up again to defend
Thomas when reports came out that Crow
paid for the private schooling of his
Grand nephew reports today that Thomas
took on his Grand nephew became his
guardian and raised him as a son all
extremely laudable things but he didn't
disclose that Crow had paid over 150 000
for the boy's private school tuition
this time though pauletta seems to have
a better defense for Thomas paletta
argues and I think he's right this time
that the relevant statute requires
disclosure of gifts for dependent
children but defines dependent children
as a son daughter step son or
stepdaughter and who is a dependent
defined by the IRS no idea why the
statute is written that way but it seems
true that Thomas's Grand nephew is not a
son daughter stepson or step-daughter
and thus this particular incident
wouldn't need to be reported there are
reports that Justice Sonia Sotomayor was
paid 3.6 million dollars for various
book deals but declined to recuse
herself from multiple copyright
infringement cases involving book
publishers or their parents or
subsidiaries now that's bad too but at
least she disclosed those issues where
Thomas seems to have hidden his
incidents completely of course the
justices really enjoy their privacy so
if you'd like to be as private as a
Supreme Court Justice you can get your
online personal data taken down with
today's sponsor in cogni now I don't
know about you but I've seen a huge
uptick in the amount of spam that I'm
getting and it's no surprise every year
the number and scope of data breaches
worldwide is rising and you might not
know it but there are hundreds of data
Brokers that possess and sell your
personal data probably right now and
their numbers are growing every year
these data Brokers could have your name
your address phone number of shopping
habits possibly even your social
security number all up for the highest
bidder I know when I checked there were
literally hundreds of different
companies that had this information at
best this leads to scam calls and at the
worst identity theft and doxing but
here's where Incognito comes in
incognate fights on your behalf to
remove your personal data from data
Brokers and deals with any objections
from their side all you have to do is
create an account and give them your
approval to work on your behalf incogni
conducts repeated ongoing removals
because even if the broker removes your
data once they could collect it again
incognitive make sure that your personal
information stays off the market for
good when I signed up I saw a huge
decrease in the number of spam emails
and calls that I was getting and it was
terrifying to see exactly how many
Brokers have our data and it's really
fun to watch incogni get them to delete
that info one by one if they fight
Incognito will actually fight back and
send repeated letters on your behalf
until that information is gone so if
you'd like to give Incognito try click
on the link below to get 60 off of
incogni when you use the code legal
eagle again to get 60 off just click on
the link that's on screen right now or
down in the description and use the code
legal eagle and after that click on this
box over here for more legal eagle or
I'll see you in court